Này từng điểm hô xerizan là một trong những công chính lix sử quan trọng nhất của Philippine.
Được xây dựng để từng nhớ bác sĩ, nhà văn vài mũ rân tộc của xerizan.
Người có vai cho quan trọng trong phân trọng đủ trang dành được lập của Philippine.
Tưởng tiếng xí rizan đúc bằng đồng và đã hoặc cường cao 12 xong mẹ.
Đặt trong khương ra không viên kê xanh dự lấn được khánh thành và ngày bà 12-12 năm,
nhưng chỉ trọng mấy ba sau 12 xong năm hô xerizan qua đời.
Công chính là biểu tượng của lòng Yun nước, giáo ruột lix sử,
nhắc nhớ thế hệ chả Philippine về tình thành yếu nước,
khi xinh vì độc lập trân tộc của hô xerizan,
mũ nâm có hàng yên ngươi dân và lãnh đạo Philippine đến đây để dân hoa tưởng liệm nguyễn hùng của rân tộc.
Mỗi không rằng xanh thư gián, đây không chỉ là nơi tưởng liệm mặc quan là diện biệm xin hoạt văn ngoá,
dài chỉ và tổ chức các sự kiện cuốc gia quan trọng của Philippine.